Greetings, developers.
This is Wesley Chun, software
engineer and developer
advocate here at Google.
Welcome to today's
episode, where
we'll walk through
the common code needed
to access Google APIs.
In the previous
episode, we showed you
how to set up an app using
Google APIs in the Dev console.
Click the link if you
missed it, as it's
needed for this episode.
Why the code walkthrough?
Because using the
same common code base,
you can access any of our APIs.
The code we'll look
at is in Python.
But you can use
any language that's
supported by the Google
API's client library.
In the end, the HTTP calls
generated by the library,
that go across the wire,
are the same regardless
of which language you use.
First, we'll look at
simple API access,
which requires an API key.
An API key will only permit
access to public data,
and obviously not authorized
data such as user information.
Before we get to
the code review,
be sure to grab the API key
from your project's credentials
page.
Now let's look at the code.
On line one, we import
the build function.
It creates a service endpoint
for interacting with an API.
The concept is the
same, but may be
slightly different
in other languages.
For example, in Java
there's a builder class
with a Build method.
In JavaScript, there's
a load function.
.NET, Objective C, and
PHP, have service class.
Line two is the API key you
copied from the dev console.
Note in production,
you're not going
to hard code an API
key into source!
It's not secure, all right.
Finally, in line three, Build
creates that service endpoint
to the API you wish to use.
And that's it.
Now for authorized
access, using OAuth 2.
Go to your projects
credentials page
again, and download
the JSON file
after you've created
those credentials.
Click on the link to
the earlier episode,
where we demoed how to do this.
And save it as
"clientsecret.JSON"
on your file system.
Now, it's no surprise
with the added security
that there's more code.
Let's break it down.
We've got the
imports at the top.
In addition to Build,
we need HTTP objects
for sine requests--
that's line two.
The final important line
three gives us token storage
from OAuth2client.file,
and utility functions
to create and run the
OAuth flow, respectively.
OAuth scopes express
the permissions
you request users to
authorize for your app.
You may need one or more scopes.
So, on line five, either
you'll have one or more strings
representing those scopes.
In Python, you can have
an interval, or one long
space delimited string.
Line six is the
clientsecret.json file
that you got from clicking
the download JSON button.
When your app is granted
access, the server
sends back an
access token, which
is stored in the
file in line eight.
Line nine is where
your app tries
to get a valid access
token with which
to make authorized API calls.
If the credentials are missing,
or invalid-- like being
expired-- lines 11 and 12 will
create and run the OAuth flow
to get a valid access token.
Which, if received, is
stored in that file.
Finally, once we have
a valid access token,
the last common step is to
create a service endpoint
to that API.
You need to specify the
API string and its version.
The last parameter
signs the HTTP calls
with your credentials.
You can get API names
and versions in the Docs.
Congratulations, now you can
make authorized API requests.
At this point, we've covered
both simple and authorized API
access.
Now you're ready to take on
any Google API, so make sure
you check out other
episodes in this series.
Click the link to get the client
library for your development
language, and review
the previous episode
on setting up your project
in the dev console.
We look forward
to seeing what you
can build using Google APIs.
This is Wesley Chun
from Google, and we'll
blast off with you, next
time on "The Launch Pad."